je mets que j'envoie tout le monde c'est
tellement pas de la faute de passe le
cauchemar a commencé il ya environ un
mois le petit geneviève était aux prises
avec de la fièvre et des maux de tête
ses parents l'ont immédiatement amené à
l'hôpital de maniwaki
on était dans l'urgence on m'a dit si tu
aimes dans leur ton à maison le vendredi
matin quelques à s'élever à s'est mis à
tomber
la fillette de 4 ans reçu son diagnostic
cinq jours plus tard à l'hôpital de
montréal pour enfants paralysie flasque
aiguë c'est une inflammation de la
moelle épinière
suite à une infection virale
probablement et puis sa cause une
paralysie soudaine aiguë qui peut
affecter aussi les muscles respiratoires
geneviève qui était en parfaite santé a
maintenant les bras et les jambes
paralysées et elle doit utiliser un
respirateur artificiel
une partie de la journée au début et
boucher pure elle peut rien maintenant
on peut bouger ses mains ses brins bouge
pas encore on pas capable de l'élever
est encore gaver depuis la fin de l'été
une soixantaine de cas de paralysie
flasque aiguë ont été rapportés aux
états unis environ une vingtaine à
toronto 4 à l'hôpital de montréal pour
enfants et 2 à 5 justin la maladie
serait entre autres provoquée par la
contraction d'un entérovirus un virus
fréquent banale qui cause habituellement
les symptômes d'un simple rhume c'est un
risque très minime
c'est un certain nombre de patients en
minorité qui vont développer la maladie
flasque aiguë à suite un virus si la
maladie est rare
il n'y a cependant pas de traitement
miracle pour la guérir les pas
d'antibiotiques ou d'antiviral compagnie
serait nécessairement pour traiter le
virus mais à l'heure actuelle a quand
même certains
thérapie qu'on peut donner principe
d'accélérer ou de maximiser la
récupération au niveau musculaire chez
ces enfants
[Musique]
si le passage de ces clones médecin
réussi à arracher quelques sourires
l'avenir de la petite demeure incertain
on va prendre le 22 mai est déjà forte
ici olivier bachand à radio canada
montréal